it's probably true in a lot of cultures
maybe every culture that food and
especially like in a family
the mother that cooks is the source of
love
and like ties the family together it
creates events where everyone comes
together
it's uh it's one of the only chances of
togetherness
the thing that bonds a family is like
dinner
or food eating together and i don't know
what to do with that
it ties up with like dieting and so on
when i was on stricter diets especially
competing and cutting weight and stuff
it feel it felt like i was almost like
losing opportunity to connect with
friends and family
it's interesting it almost like cultures
we cannot fully experience love and
family without
eating and on the flip side of that
eating enables us to experience
love and family i don't know what to do
with that
it's a tough one because there's lots of
layers around kind of
gender roles and families changing and
things
yeah i'd say i agree around the
alienation
and i've done carnivore diet and i've
tried some of these extreme protocols
and i too
i suffered from loneliness you know it
was like doing carnivore and
and not being able to eat what my kids
ate and talk about at the same time
those pieces are real and i wonder with
all of these diets
if that structure is actually helping or
just taking away from
people's kind of sensual understanding
um but i think that there's some rigor
around that that helps people discover
what's good for them
by eliminating and then growing towards
more intuitive food
is a good evolution from that base i
love
to cook for people i love to
pay attention to their their
way of being and read what they'd like
to eat and it's my
my purest way of love and that's for
everybody
in my life i actually love to cook for
people i love you know i don't i
i would struggle to be you know putting
out food all the time it's like
something for me it's a real act of care
taking
so i definitely have that in my makeup
um and and i definitely notice
um in times of like of of real stress
that's the piece that drops off right
then and it's like if i'm unable to care
for myself i have a hard time cooking so
it's
for me it's very emotional it's very
connected to love
you